Since as women age they naturally create less estrogen, can we ever just stop worried about taking a robotase inhibitors for hormone-positive cancer?
My mom also had breast cancer surgery only. She is 82. Does she really need to suppress estrogen any longer?
Yeah, that is a question. That's why I think it's a good idea to measure your estrogen levels.
Typically when the robotase inhibitors came out they were used for shorter periods of time.
Then they went to, you got to be on this for a couple of years. Then they went to, you got to be on this for five years.
Now they're telling women you got to be on this for 10 years. They're telling some people you got to be on this the rest of your life.
Really? How much estrogen are you producing post-menopausal?
Well, you are still producing some. Even if you had a hysterectomy and had your ovaries removed, where is the estrogen coming from?
Remember your adrenals make estrogen to our less than your ovaries ever have made.
But your adrenals will, that's what your estrogens coming from. And estrogen aromatises from other hormones as well.
And you get zero estrogens in your body as well. So there argument is that, well because of those things that your adrenals are still producing estrogen,
you are creating estrogen as byproducts of aromatisation of other hormones.
And you're picking up zero estrogens in your environment, you should be on an aromatase inhibitor the rest of your life.
Well, maybe you could measure it. Maybe you could go back and say I don't want to be on the same dosage.
Maybe you could say, you know, I've gone through menopausal not producing very much. I'm staying and watching my diet and staying away from as many zero estrogens as possible.
I know it's not completely possible. Can't I just measure it? And they just go from there.
That makes more sense. And we hear the medical doctors all through the last two decades have talked about personalised medicine, yada yada yada, but never seemed to actually do it.
So that seems much more personalised where you're measuring and seeing, hey, look at my estrogens are extremely low.
Why do I need to stay on an aromatase inhibitor? Good question.
That should be posed to the doctor. And when you get the answer of, well, this is just what we do.
You can say, well, I think it's time to find another doctor. This is not personalised medicine.